five four three you're listening to the
hp
yes i am in a raging state of ketosis
clearly the nutrition didn't work
i can't be
it's just awkward because i'm like this
far i gotta scoot over a little bit okay
stop that i don't love you all right i
do love you
it just feels weird either keeps going
scoot over scoot over so i'm like over
here
like all my stuff's here you screwed
over to me
[Music]
so the nutri system didn't work i hate
first of all i don't recommend nutrition
right nope by the way looking over all
the food they give me
for that nutri system it's like all
super
unhealthy [ __ ] you see it it's all dead
muffins they're like bagel i mean that's
a lot of bread
it's all bread because i was looking for
keto snacks last night
and i couldn't use a single uh
one of those now zach listen i know you
guys are worried about me
and well you should be but zach lost
like 100 pounds of keto and so who are
we to question
is that i say zach you're my guru now i
am your guru your sponsor i will always
be here to help
so i was okay with that until i kind of
understood more
about what is the state of ketosis that
you're
you're trying to achieve the
enlightenment that's that's
here go ahead i'll show you what how
okay tell us dan was telling me it's
basically you're pushing your body to
survival mode
well that doesn't sound healthy
and last night i made ethan a great
salad nobody said it was healthy
the best salad and i put in it lots of
veggies and garbanzo beans
and zac said you can't eat garbanzo
beans nope no beans
no beans er carbs it has carbs ela
that's not the same this is what it
feels like to be on ketosis
right joe rogan's in a constant state of
ketosis i saw him like pee on a stick
and it turned like black
because i guess like the darker the
better and so he peed on the stick and
it was like
like tar black and he's like i am in a
state of
and that he like flew off he could fly
wow zach was just telling me before the
show that there's pee
sticks to pee on it and see how ketosis
you are yeah that's what i was just
saying joe rogan
does he really do that yeah he did it
he's if he's he's always in a state of
ketosis and you know i strive to be more
like joe rogan as possible
when i meant dude i'm gonna be in such a
state of ketosis that when they try to
give me the vaccine the needle will just
break off of my arm
that sounds like you died and you're it
doesn't even enter my body
so tonight i'll be having if you guys
are curious my keto dinner
will be
hot stuffed jalapenos with cream cheese
wrapped in bacon and then
four that's just the warm-up and then
and then for
din like dinner dinner like second
dinner steak
with a whole slab of butter and then
apparently
um i drink the butter first right zach
and then more bacon
yeah i don't like this and i
am not approving of well what if i start
losing weight you'll
you'll see okay you lose weight but but
you're not going to be healthy
i know you're going to be studly dude
we're also trying to get pregnant
lose weight or die trying i don't think
it's good for trying to get pregnant if
you're not healthy
dude in his favor become more potent
yeah i doubt it look at joe rogan you
know that guy's fertile as [ __ ]
super sperm dude yeah so are you gonna
take off a brain
i've been on it for six months can't you
tell
so anyway that's my new diet guys stick
with me here i'm just
i'm trying everything you know everyone
says i'm doing fat dye but
the one normal thing that would be
healthy and good
which is like get actual help get
someone to
put together a diet for you get someone
to exercise
oh my god get a person to do this get a
presentation of that
yes get out of my life i don't need more
people in my life especially during
covid i would
want to be left alone to eat bacon and
[ __ ] cream cheese
and steak and butter and cheese
right zach what else oh zach goes just
hit some miracle whip
no no no ready whip i'm ready for the
calorie account there's like less than
one gram of sugar in there
it's a great snack great
i i agree this diet seems cuckoo as [ __ ]
i say can i eat beans no beans
no beans how can you not eat beans beans
it's such a healthy arms they have carbs
but that's a healthy one
what does kenneth copeland think about
beans when is kenneth copeland think
about
beans i'm okay with cutting bread and
cookies that makes sense
great um pasta fine you don't need it
what's the problem with beans you're
asking for the virus
what you're asking for the virus
you're asking for what okay whatever
shut up kenneth you don't know anything
so anyway today welcome to after dark
obviously today's episode is sponsored
by liquid iv
i'm your host the fresh prince of dead
air
with my queen beside me
uh i'm more i mean you're the queen i'm
the
prince if we can say that like
if you're the prince is usually the
queen's son no no no no that's not true
if if the queen like for example queen
elizabeth was the monarch
when she gets married he doesn't become
king because king is like
higher ranking prince
prince as a prince you're right but it
still sounds like you're my son
well i like that mommy
mommy daddy change my diaper mommy stop
daddy mommy dumb i like that mommy dumb
anyway today's just a fun we're just
gonna have a fun
episode here today because i know y'all
been been saying the drama is too hot
it's too heavy
it's too much i agree we went in deep i
thought it was important
i'm pulling back we're having fun
welcome to africa
back to the roots cool
uh so i'm in a state of raging ketosis
thank you thank you and then also i want
to talk about ela getting
inseminated yeah why do you want to talk
about that
well i feel like we always share our
pregnancy journeys
and people like me okay all right
fine
it's interesting okay so we've tried and
just regular timing it and everything
ovulation days whatever it didn't work
so um
they gave me the skills to take that
make you ovulate more
and i guess we thought i just take the
pills and then we keep doing it normally
but we didn't realize
it's also you need to do insemination
yeah it's crazy it's like so that means
we go to the hot or we go to this
not hospital no it's a fertility clinic
on the same day i bust into a cup
and then they like scoop it up with like
a turkey baster
base probably something like that a
turkey baster
oh and i mean it's probably i mean it's
gotta work by the same mechanic why are
you
they basically they base you like a
turkey with my
nut okay that's why i don't want to talk
about this stuff because you make it
so gross well it is gross
it doesn't need to be that gross so we
go to
the fertility clinic and then they scoop
what do they scoop it up and then shove
it in
well they have tools yeah it's a lab
but you know what i said to them i said
okay if we're not like having sex and
this is taking place in a lab
i go how do i know it's my kid i don't
want some redheaded little [ __ ] kid
coming out of you like they put their
own feminine you know
like i guarantee that's happened in fact
somebody
someone looked that up i guarantee
that's happened before where they use
the wrong semen
and so i said how do you how do i know
that you can use the right signal
because i don't want like a little
with peace and love like a black baby
coming at you what i'm just saying
stop it not that i don't it's not that i
care that you know they're a different
race but
i would just know it's not my child
it would be it would be shocking to say
the least
i don't know i feel like you're
guaranteed that happened
you kind of have to like boom ian found
it
i'm just saying look at this doctor you
sperm to father
what hold on what is this
what doctor used his sperm oh
the doctor did it he used his sperm to
father hundreds of babies with patients
over four decades
okay uh holy crap
i don't want to do it no is this the guy
with the giant band-aid on his head
wait did he go to jail let's find out
this just happened in december this is
so disturbing why would you do this
i was gonna tell you stop with a
conspiracy no
this is real [ __ ] because i'm not
because i don't see it going in
so seeing is believing you know what i
mean
a revered family doctor may have
fathered hundreds of children using his
own sperm
without his patients knowledge he is
let me see if he's going to jail or
being sued or what
one of the siblings approached in
december
says that he admitted to being father
and to using his own sperm to father
multiple babies both that sperm donor in
the late 40s and
his medical practice as ogbyn
i can't imagine a worse betrayal
ever as a doctor
he's the hall says he has been matched
by up to five
half siblings on the website 23andme
since she submitted her dna test
but believes there could be hundreds
more all of us were born in the same
hospital
all of our birth certificates show he
was our ogbyn
not bcg ob gyn what do i say he's saying
ogb
omg word straight jack
all right joe you're not won the lecture
it says he was
he was our guy no not our father
then i discovered one of his grandsons
on there and he came up as my half
nephew sharing 12.3 dna
with me and then i have final undeniable
proof and i shared it
dude this guy better be in jail this guy
this is too much this guy
and i this is too this is infuriating
someone just look up and tell me what
happened to this guy i need to know
so do we not do the insemination this is
terrifying well that's what i
that's what i was trying to convey to
you that that prospect scared me like
this old deal with the band-aid on his
[ __ ] head is going to put his jizz in
you
mm-hmm well does it happen the same day
does happen the same day so they think
you need a chain of custody you need
you need eyes on that vial the whole way
that's what i oh
and so well what i i told them i
expressed my concern and i wonder if you
could
ask for that like just follow it
right i mean look i know it's like
overly paranoid but we're talking about
our
our child here like i can't doubt that
that you know what i mean i don't want a
roommate in any room do you see what i'm
saying
i see what you're saying i'm terrified
now so anyway i shared my concerns with
them and they say
we only pre we only do one at a time
we only have every one sample at a time
they're saying get a female doctor we do
have a female doctor but it goes through
a lab
and goes through different people in a
lab
yeah and then it's delivered to them the
same day so like
ab you want to follow my semen sample to
make sure that i'm funny business
whatever you need
i'm there no i don't um
amy might do a swap god stop it [ __ ] you
who can i trust stop okay this
conversation is over
just because you have lena doesn't have
siemens i trust her
you have go ahead you have my permission
oh what happened to that guy did anyone
find out what happened to that mother
[ __ ] was he put to death
from the looks of that picture uh he was
on it wasn't that story
yeah i mean
maybe we don't need the insemination
because basically
i'm ovulating more with the pills and
then we just have regular
but it does seem like more accurate
because they like
insert it in so it seems like a good
idea it's just
it's just it just makes me nervous
yeah you can imagine that kid comes out
and he's got red hair
i don't care about what the kid might
have it's not that he has red hair it's
just not my kid
i'm i know i just don't like your joke
it's just annoying me
okay that's fair enough
so that's that that's what i'm dealing
with right now
do you have any side effects of those
pills you're taking
no
yeah maybe we could just do it i mean
that you know what i mean can't go wrong
with that
yeah i could just scoop up my
um okay turkey based you myself i mean
how hard could it be
no something is about
to bust i mean i've cooked i've prepared
thanksgiving dinner
any intel on that guy it's fate i'm
googling around uh
this article seems to be the most recent
thing oh yeah it just happened in
december so it's recent news
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god i hate that
guy
so much what would compel you to do that
like you're not even involved in their
lives
it's like why would you do that what
kind of sick
thrill is that
it says at the end of this article he's
104 ian said
he's probably passed away already now
this was from december that [ __ ]
still kick it
yeah there was another guy uh dr quincy
48
that there was a documentary recently
about on hbo baby god
who fathered at least 24 children using
his own sperm
oh so this isn't the first time this is
not the first time okay
he's called baby god no by the way
in the same in the same clinic there is
there is a male doctor i don't see him
but
he's probably not even all the samples
no i saw him a couple of times when my
doctor wasn't
uh available yeah and he's a weirdo
it was like while he's giving me the
ultrasound
with you know it's like vaginal
uncomfortable
he was telling me jokes trying to keep
you
but like like because i'm israeli he was
telling me like
about his jewish family where
they were not funny or i didn't want to
hear that
it was weird it was very weird
i don't like that yeah
oh brother so just we're not doing that
that's what i'm saying i
when the semen leaves my eye it then
goes out of the picture like it's like
the magic trick like once it's out of
frame
and it comes back in the frame you don't
know what kind of slide a hand happened
i'm just saying i'm just saying i just
feel like especially now if we were in
like the same office okay
and then i like nutted in the bathroom
and then brought it out and then they
scooped it and put it in you
i would do that all right it's
especially after
i had the weird encounter with the word
doctor that i'm like
didn't you tell me about that because it
was just whatever i just said that guy
is dead i was like well
he's not my doctor i don't know i
probably have 300 kids
that guy's the baby he's baby
he is the baby god yeah
that option shout out to his family
and the big family
[Laughter]
oh man it was like the jokes were
just weird like i'm trying to remember i
feel like i when i'm uncomfortable i
kind of like just try to forget about it
so i
well it's like trying to like not even
remember what happened but it was kind
of
talking about how like um it has like
jewish family and
there they made this inappropriate joke
during a dinner about how like they have
more sex on the weekends
i don't know i don't know it was so
weird like seriously
that's complain
maybe people who do that are that's just
if he's making sexual jokes while he's
doing a vaginal ultrasound
that's you should complain about him he
needs to stop that guy is a fathering
children that he
see that's why you see why like um i'm
not saying i'm
this wasn't that big of a deal no but
i'm not a victim
of anything but like the situation was
so uncomfortable i was just trying to go
along with it and then forget about it
and that's just a glimpse into like what
happens when you're
abused or something right it's just like
a tiny glimpse of that
red flag unbelievable
how old is he it's like i don't know
scott
he's old fergal oh he's old fifty
something still fertile
yeah yeah interesting
okay well that's don't worry there we
are
regular after dark state of ketosis
people
[Music]
i'm glad you shared my paranoia though
because i thought i was being paranoid
yeah
but immediately when they they told me
about the procedure i was like
oh that was my first thought
cause i'm gonna get the baby god seaman
not ethan semen
and trust me that could probably be
better off with baby god seaman but
let's be honest
that's not the point you better off with
anyone else's semen
that's not the point right elo
oh jesus oh let's talk about teddy fresh
you have that video dan
we got a new teddy fresh collection that
i want to prim
actually it's not even pro i just want
to show off eela's beautiful work it's
between you two right now
oh cool that's hot so let's see this was
restocked
because and it sold out immediately
again which is nuts but this photo is so
cool
you're not showing that though he's
showing the video we prepared media
okay i mean this is okay all right we
got media out here beanies
female beanies mature
socks of stripes of [ __ ]
this that that's hot and everything else
this isn't that good i'd rather just
show up what
okay whatever you want okay here oh i
can show everything it's like how it
shows close-ups and [ __ ]
uphill sweater such a classic sold out
immediately
pretty crazy but this is really
something you know this is like high
level designer [ __ ] so
not surprised holler at your girl eel
cline this one was
really fun because it's one of my
sketchbook pages that um
i just like that we were able to
translate it
into this pretty cool yeah it took us a
while to get it right with the colors
and the textures
and to make it really work and then like
originally the buttons weren't
the wheels and then we had the idea to
use buttons and everything came together
it was very nice
teamwork that was our that was actually
our customer support look this idea
the buttons oh it was
oh that's hot so
this is the cardigan with the bear head
print bada bing bada boom you know what
time it is
um this is pretty cool how's this doing
this is
a female it's not it's unison oh it's
unisex
who cares then it's a vest what
um this shirt is really cool put some
rhinestones just trying to [ __ ] around
with rhinestones you know what i mean
studs oh studs you're right how very
right you are
anyway let me just blast through this
teddyfresh.com you got the studs you got
the cardigans you got the sweaters
you got the zip shirts these are gone
you can't get this
oh this one fast printer is
next week i think there's a couple of
items that were
late so that would be delivery too
oh we made masks i wish i had one of
those here right now with me
yeah the masks are cool that took a
while to get right man
i've been trying to make those masks
likes longest time
anyway head on over to teddyfish.com
elo's crushing it as usual oh this is
one shirt i really want to
shout out this was the shirt that i'm
wearing right now
we did it used to say what did it say i
have crippling anxiety oh i had
crippling anxiety
and a lot of people got very angry at us
because they felt we were
capitalizing on
profit but little do they know uh
it's true from my perspective
because i through that we're profiting
from mental health
right
yeah i don't i don't we actually well it
turned out nice we donated all the money
from that
first round and we donated
it to um mental health i think yeah
we don't like that mental health yeah in
america
yeah we don't know like 30 50 000 i
don't remember the exact amount
and they just reached out to us wanting
to collab because they're like hey
thanks for the cheddar so i was like
that sounds like fun but um
anyway it's back we changed it to 2020
is over my life still sucks
but hey for you those of you guys who
got the first edition
super rare you got the first edition
it's like a pokemon yeah so
2020 is over and my life still sucks
so it's a little bit of a timepiece even
eh
there you have it buy this shirt before
someone before we have to
wait you know how much how do you know
how much we donated a b because we said
oh we tweeted it we donated forty four
thousand three hundred and seventy two
dollars
shout out to his family shout out to the
family bro
anyway okay what else we got
uh
that's what we got
you guys want to do the impression
competition with uh
mojessa how do you say his name
the joe biden guy
so here let me pull up the video uh
i wanted to do an impression competition
with muhammad where he
here let me show some of his videos can
someone link it at the top of my
document here uh
we always are quoting or whatever his
name is
wake up and trying to do the best
impression we can so i thought let's
wake up let's do let's do an impression
so let me show one of the videos
to give you know to refresh your guys's
memory and then we'll have a
a impression competition and i didn't
prepare for it though
i would like to practice what do you
want to do is just we've been practicing
for like a month
okay
wake up 9 11. wake up
okay so here's the joe biden guy just to
refresh you guys memory we love him
we're trying to get him on the show
zach's on the trail
i'm so deep i'm so close to getting you
wake up
here he is 911.
what happened 2001
what
dan is the king of uh so work of this
we're gonna have to um take a a vote
with the audience
ian you want to start us off i feel like
oh yeah let's see what you do
i'm making the poll right now hold on
okay oh love
how you feeling you want to start us off
i feel like you might have a video
[Laughter]
oh you're muted wake up now you're
living
there you are you're putting me on the
spot here monk we're all
this was not planned you're putting all
of us on the screen yeah
yes okay okay okay so just joe biden
go buy them 911
[Music]
just maybe a little less hot on the mic
oh not
not straightens the mic okay
um joe biden nine eleven
all right meet your my king because you
have music thank you
no that's no that's zach oh zach is
actually playing uh
segment music yes oh
fantastic a b you want to give us your
best shot
joe biden joe biden bad boy trump
i think you gotta dig a little deeper
yeah
you gotta like eleven
all right thank you a.b ela you want to
go i mean i think you're pretty good at
it
well here you want to watch this watch
yeah refresh your mind
what happened 2001 what happened
wake up what happened 2001
that was good i'm 9 11.
i can't do it so it takes a long time
it's good though i appreciate that for
you doug d
that's what i like that's all i can say
dug deep
all right ian it's your turn
that's pretty good
oh hmm
[Laughter]
2001. but i didn't wake up
your buddies and snack you ready now
you're living
today what go ahead zach let's hear what
you got
this method from jalapeno
there you go maybe
one we could have someone call in with
the if they think they have a really
good impression
yeah maybe we could have a competition
for the best
impression in the audience
all right the moment is now dan dan
it's your time to shine we all know you
you're building up way too much
dan is definitely the most committed
it's just that i've watched it the most
well nah you don't make it wake up
wake up this message from
very good that was good
okay here i go let me listen to it
dance tough one now you're living
[Music]
all right here i go the competition is
stiff especially with dan coming in
i think the trick is to like not use
your tongue yeah you gotta act like it's
like swollen you don't have teeth yeah
okay okay
draw by then wake up this is a message
from
9 11. what happened 2000
two thousand one yo buy them
nine eleven nine eleven
wake up you wake up
wake up pretty good i think the girl's
closed the girl's doing you a favor here
right all right
let's see yeah all right drop your butt
boy you're a bad boy jordan
you're a bad boy
i'm gonna vote for myself because no you
know what i'm not that egotistical i'm
not gonna vote
you know what i'm gonna vote for you but
you guys
who do i think did the best uh
i'm just gonna see the results guys i'm
not gonna vote i'm not gonna is it at
the chat i don't see it yeah ian
spamming it i just pinned oh who voted
for a b
who voted for a b there's one vote what
maybe
yeah exactly it was good i saw a lot of
zeros out of ten in the
audience so yes that was probably wavy
just oh wow dan is just like i'm not
even close on this one
he looks pretty going pretty high too
wait ian you're not even on here what
the heck
oh what why'd you not add yourself ian
oh
shoot i forgot the integrity of the pool
start over get this
out of here bro you gotta yeah i know
according to the uh
according to these the the personality
test
ian doesn't exist pretty much he got
like a zero right
he's just i'm stroking [ __ ] down here
right
dude you don't have to let us know you
gotta recast that
ian outrageous do we have any people who
want to call in and give their best joe
biden
uh if we're going to do that we should
take a minute to
to zach maybe you can get some good
contestants
we're actually uh coming up on uh break
time anyway so we should probably do
that
wake up
wake up you wake up wake up
man i got a ton of great videos here
today to watch with you guys
okay here's the new straw poll
with ian above
i'm voting for a b because he voted for
him cell phone
we caught him then your link i don't
appreciate you oh so ian is coming in
pretty hot now i don't know if that's
because
he didn't add himself right oh dan no
dan's taking the lead
oh but he handed a better one than me
now why am i lower than eli
and ian when last time i was second
place this is some dog [ __ ]
he is a legend wait this [ __ ] is weird
you guys why
okay now dan hmm
okay stop the count stop the gun
i got a [ __ ] zero percent you only
get
well love poor guy not to be fair i
think the accent doesn't help
it's hard he's got a swedish accent and
he's doing this guy's middle eastern
accent
who's speaking there's a lot of layers
wow there's a lot of movement
this is pretty exciting i mean ian and
dan are in close competition
gila too much neck and neck not that
close to me well you're beating me which
does hurt i'm not going to lie it does
hurt look at this
this election was a fraud ian are you
impressed that you're
getting so high on this dan totally
okay let's get one more from you guys
give me give me your best 911
from ian and then yeah yeah
who goes go ahead ian ian first give me
your best shot
joe
you want me to play i lost it you want
me to play it sure
yeah let's refresh your memory stay
energized
this is important the people deserve to
yeah okay so how you fix that dan
i unplug it and replug it back in the
classic is it a computer issue
yeah okay we bought a new computer but
because all these bitcoin miners you can
kill the music zack thank you
all these bitcoin miners are buying all
the graphics cards in the world bitcoin
bitcoin why are people so excited about
bitcoin it is ruining
society we have no graphics cards
people are literally just is that really
what's happening
yes oh my gosh well that's it that's
part of it
they're buying graphics cards and you
know what they just they waste so much
electricity
like so many servers what's the deal
they're like well i guess you mine
bitcoin
bitcoin
it uses a graphics card to do it and so
a lot of people buy
up you're solving like complicated
algorithms
and so you need like lots of computing
power but as far as i can tell correct
me if i'm wrong
there is no it's not like doing
meaningful work it's just
blasting energy into the void right like
it's not actually working towards any
meaningful end i mean it depends on your
point of view on if bitcoin is a
good thing or a bad thing i guess no but
like they're what algorithm are they
you know what i mean like we're not like
trying to figure out like how to bl how
to go to mars or some [ __ ] it's just
literally some dumb blockchain [ __ ]
uh that yeah yes it's not
it's not solving the problem that is
being solved is not
useful in of itself yes right exactly i
thought it was
yeah that would be nice right no so
you've got tons of people just like
processing thousands of graphics there's
like
farms of computers yeah i saw this
really interesting documentary there's a
really big bit uh coin farming operation
like iceland
and the reason it's there is because
they don't have to cool
the computers they suck in the air from
the outside and blow it through the
servers
and so that that's crazy saving money on
the cooling actually gives them the edge
on farming
to to be profitable
let's huh i think so you know someone
pointed out that your nutrisystem is
very wasteful with all that packaging
of everything okay um i'm
bad i eat too much i'm wasteful
everything is not talking about you
we're talking about
i agree it's a [ __ ] it's a training
product yeah it's a train wreck
okay you said we have to do a break yeah
uh we sure do
all right let's do a break when we come
back i have tons of funds videos to
watch
lots of goofs and gaffs we're going to
have so much fun
don't go away liquid
iv
liquid iv is helping me accomplish my
new year's resolution i am trying to
lose weight by any means necessary
and liquid iv helps me keep hydrated you
know it's stressful it's hard work
whatever it's doing
pour some of that liquid iv in a cup of
water and you are getting
super hydrated because liquid iv is more
hydrating
than water is that possible
yes according to them
uh i have just one goal
okay and first of all what helps me get
there i like the hydration liquid iv can
you show it off dan
dan was screaming his head off during
the pokemon on
on
damn why don't you hit that liquid iv
interesting
so let's see you know you just pour in a
pack you mix it up
and you've got a beautiful refreshing
cup
of hydrating liquid iv hit that
feel the course through your veins feel
the cure hydrating
[Applause]
powerful
how's that that's impressive
that was a go ahead dan how was that
drink was good he's good
see you're here you feel hydrated
yeah nice not a boy they all so here's
the deal that's just the hydrating one
but they have a few other
flavors watermelon lemon lime passion
fruit they even
launched strawberry hello
and they have different they have like a
um
keep your body uh what's it called no
not
yeah that is one but that's the one i'm
thinking of
that is another one what's the one where
they protect your body from
[ __ ] no immune
yes thank you they have an immune boost
one
and they have a caffeine one now i like
the caffeine one because i'm not
necessarily
into drinking coffee because i have a
gerd and it
makes my gerd situation bad so i can get
a jolt
of hydrating caffeine from liquid iv
the caffeine one the energy one so
that's what it is i love liquid iv
super easy to use tastes great
that's how it is baby first thing in the
morning before a workout when you feel
run down daily hydration maintenance
hangover cures
etc it's good for all of that
so grab your strawberry liquid iv or any
of the other great flavors
in bulk at nationwide at costco oh wow
let's
go dude you could probably buy like 10
000 of these at costco
i just realized how much i missed costco
i know i haven't been in costco
god knows a year yeah
is this dude are they still are you sure
dan they put it there
are they still doing samples at costco
or is that like a dead meme probably not
wow bro come on that's just
that's just a tragedy dude that's
unforgivable anyway go to costco
or get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com and use code
h3 at checkout that's 25 off
anything when you order when you use the
promo code h3 at liquidity.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com
promo code h3o
thank you we are back and
fully hydrated yep
all right let's move it on you know i've
got all this there's so many crazy
media from what's happening in texas you
guys know that like
this crazy cold storm way beyond the
normal
hit texas and their power grid went out
and all these poor people in texas are
like
their toilet water is freezing i mean
can you imagine it's like below freezing
and you don't have heat
no i don't know what to what do you do i
know i saw
reports of people like burning their
furniture oh and
to keep warm people are sleeping in
their cars a lot of stuff like that
there's like warming shelters joel
austin
is like letting people freeze to death
outside his church
that's actually partially true he he got
[ __ ] again and then
again joel osteen waited until people
gave him a ton of [ __ ]
until he opened his church nice guy
but there's the one thing that's been
happening a lot that i've been following
on tick tock
is that people's pipes are busting
which see i've never lived in freezing
i've never lived in freezing cold
temperatures so forgive me if i'm
coming off as ignorant because i just
don't know a lot about this but
if i guess you're supposed to leave your
water running yeah
because if the water remains stagnant
and freezes and when it freezes it
expands and the pipes
bust and then you get these crazy leaks
wow
so that's what's been happening i think
texas just aren't used to
freezing temperatures in colder areas
the plumbing is
insulated too but it's not right because
they're not oh
this doesn't ever happen in texas so
they're not the infrastructure's not
there the people don't know how to
handle it oh
god so and then obviously the power grid
wasn't prepared so
people are like freezing to death
actually which is very
very uh tragic and a [ __ ] and it's been
like a week now you know what i mean
um was this something that they knew was
coming
like yes they knew it for a week
yeah it's there's actually here if you
guys are curious
now i'm not gonna get too heavy here i
just there's like so many interesting
videos
of like pipes bursting and houses
flooding and just crazy [ __ ] that i've
never seen it's all over tick tock
uh that i thought it'd be interesting to
watch with peace and love
possible but this lady is faring better
than texas
here's what it is a really good
explanation oklahoma actually shares a
power grid
with its neighbors here's what it breaks
down to the state gets its energy from
the southwest power pool
along with 13 other states so when the
temperature dipped down
in oklahoma and demand went up the pool
had enough energy are we having audio
issues or is she
reserved to respond to this emergency
like omar said texas has its own power
grid
that is run by the company ercot it
doesn't have the luxury of relying on
other states for help
so basically texas is the yeehaw we're
the lone state
boys no regulations no regulation no
central government we don't like
we will job by the number he's just
under everything
yeah because of texas's whole like we
ain't we ain't got
to deal with no other state boys amen
you know so now that their grid got
super overloaded because everyone was
trying to keep their house
the power just went [ __ ] dead on the
whole stage
crazy meanwhile joe biden 3am the
governor of texas is like
11. what happened
2001. he's like wake up
what's happening anyway it's not funny a
lot of people are in really dire
situations but the videos are very
interesting
let's see guys um so this is
my house yeah these are just pipes
busting
in the freezing cold and like it's just
it's so [ __ ] up
so they were supposed to leave water
running to avoid this
well some people did it and it just it
still didn't help because the
the pipes weren't just built for this
yeah oh my god
it's awful it's been 40 hours no power
40 hours no power
it's freezing it hasn't snowed here
since 1973
wow our hot tub and pull
literally frozen
it's it's it's crazy you know people
don't realize but
this is quite the effect of climate
change more extreme weather
poor ducks it's crazy i'm sure it won't
change anyone in texas's mind you're
surviving baby
[Music]
oh i don't need that whole i don't need
that whole inspirational music
but this is so so i can't even i
wouldn't even know what to do i don't
know what to
do i always had heat in my house bro
i'm in the bathroom with the steam on
brothers
oh god i'm coming pay you
i got about 10 jackets on oh my god i
don't think i'm gonna make it no more
so who got heated they has bro i'm
coming over i'm gonna pay you
how cold is it oh it's like at night
it's like 10 degrees
and they're [ __ ] hot yeah no it's
it's
bad it's really bad
and your hope they've gotten churned hey
man
yeah i mean that's your house dude
and it's like 10 degrees
[Music]
it's tick-tock everybody gotta have wake
up
governor what's the governors of texas
names i believe abbott
governor abbott wake up this [ __ ] guy
when it started happening all this [ __ ]
he gets on the tv and
starts blaming green energy it's the
craziest thing i've ever seen
yeah so this is happening a lot i was
shocked my whole tick tock feed is just
full
of videos like this i think the whole
narrative around the green energy thing
was because uh they're they have a lot
of windmills in texas and they froze
and they're like oh see it's not
reliable but um
i think the whole thing is that they
just didn't prepare for it because
there's
there's windmills and cold climates all
over the place
and they don't freeze well the the what
i read was that gas pipes are freezing
and that was the big
right that i'm saying that's what his
narrative was yeah it's it
it's coming out that it seems like it
was largely a failure of the gas
infrastructure in texas and also not
being attached to any other grid for no
[ __ ]
good reason like there's a you know what
i mean smart grid is
is one of the best from the bet you need
a whole unified grid because sometimes
you need more energy here less energy
there
this guy's burning his child's uh
he's burning some kind of furniture to
grill outside so i can at least cook
something hot
jesus kenneth oh yeah this person's fan
fro there's ted cruz going to cancun
i didn't put i wasn't planning to talk
about that but ted cruz is a senator
from texas that everybody hates
and he bounced the [ __ ] state
and went to cancun with his family can
you imagine dude it's crazy
shout out to his family yeah he also got
a horrible haircut
you noticed that yes oh my god bro
i really
i just can't believe this
she forgot to do the dishes again like
how many times
yeah good for her
for keeping a good attitude
oh
[Music]
people saying fled cruz
and when they're like they're probably
stuck without food too
well grocery stores like there's no
power uh
[Music]
well there's people we have people from
texas lined up maybe we can ask them
yeah people there was like i saw a clip
there was like one dominoes open
and they sold like a weeks of food in
two hours or something
let's talk to someone from texas
let me get it set up cool
what oh [ __ ]
oh that's a campus oh my god
wow that looks so [ __ ] up
that is gonna be so much damage
stairwell looks like the titanic
[Music]
look at this it looks like the universal
studio is set
holy my good dude
man i have a caller
lined up what's his name her name um
miguel miguel bring him in
he is on the line miguel
miguel and there's a line hello hello
hello outside reporting for duty
do you have uh heat do you have power
um yeah yeah i've been lucky enough to
have uh to have power and
water working um did it ever go out for
you
it it hasn't except for yesterday um
you know how we've been we've been
saying that something is about the bus
to all my
water pipes busted yesterday so wow oh
yeah yeah yeah so what happened i'm not
you know i
i had to um i had to get out and drive
to uh to a hardware store
and buy some things and i came back you
know i'm not a plumber i don't know i
don't know anything about it i was just
hammering stuff
trying to do like a temporary fix um
but it ended up busting bursting again
today oh no this morning
so wow so inside your house where's this
pipe located
it's outside okay so it's not ruining
your property or anything
uh no not the not the interior it's all
outside
seems like you were lucky yeah yeah so
are you able to get food what's the
situation like there on the ground
yeah so um when was it i went to go
get food on wednesday when i went to the
hardware store i came back and i noticed
that
this local supermarket was open when i
went in
um the lights were off it was dark
oh great like they did not have power
so i walked in uh and the only thing you
saw
or you could see were these little beams
of light which were just
people with their cell phones out like
oh my god
so i was able to get a couple things and
on my way to check out
i hadn't realized that they had signs
outside that said um
cash only which makes sense because they
don't have any power right
but i hadn't realized that and i was
i guess i was visit visibly panicking
because
this very nice gentleman came up to me
and he handed me a 20.
yeah he handed me a 20 to buy my stuff
wow that's so awesome
yeah yeah so shout out to his family
what a guy
you know i offered to venmo him and then
paypal him back but uh
yeah you know he refused so he was very
very kind
if only joel osteen had a heart like
that man
[Applause]
texas would be saved already
where do you live in texas what city i'm
in austin
oh yeah downtown yeah how do you how do
you
how do you feel about ted cruz bouncing
to cancun
um you know it's uh
no it's [ __ ]
but i just i wonder because people keep
electing ted cruz like by a lot like
people actually like ted cruz in texas
which is weird because it's the only
but whatever it's not that but are
people angry about that
in texas or people like ah it's ted cruz
what was he going to do
i i'm like i spend all day browsing on
twitter because i have nothing else to
do
and um yeah people are all just just
roasting him and that's all i see on my
feet
um i see people blaming it on
five g it's the 5g 5b
wait how is it 5g
that's well i believe it i mean i
it's not that much of a stretch of the
imagination after everything we've seen
last year
yeah was it antifa is anyone saying that
yet
i'm sure yeah yesterday i went to
another
another grocery store i was in the line
for maybe like an
hour and a half wow yeah just uh just to
buy like
yeah eggs and milk or whatever yeah yeah
well so it's tough i'm hoping that
clears soon and i'm glad you're
you're doing okay yeah yeah we finally
we got some sun today
uh it's been very opaque and i think
that's
that's been very um demoralizing for
people here
but hopefully it starts to look up and
um
yeah yeah well god bless you miguel
uh god bless that man who gave you a 20
what a legend
i know right be that man shout out to
his family
all right dude stay warm all right take
an honor thank you
all right bye miguel everybody
staying warm in texas good people in
texas
there you go of course well also austin
is like the
cool area no is it i don't know austin
rocks
it does yeah i love austin okay good for
austin
so that's texas yada yada i have a
question for you
uh zach would you
i know you like doula aleppo is she like
your celebrity crush doula
do a lipa i think i'm off to do a lipa
train
what what what well considering what
you're about to show because of that why
do you know what i was
they use the image of james charles
instead of dua lipa
for real why they thought it was her
oh my god my sister he was recreating
one of her looks with this photo so yeah
i have i have the side-by-side in the uh
let's see it
wow sister so you won't fight you
wouldn't
i thought you might go for it zach
honestly it just totally threw me the
other direction
here it is it's actually so close
that's why it's yeah
this is not okay that james charles
ruined your dual leap of fantasy
uh he's ruined my fantasies stole the
teddy fresh hoodie i mean this was a
menace to society
yeah i'll agree with you on that one
you know the thing these days i've
noticed with girls is they
they get their eyebrows all all like
they like glue their eyebrows so that
you can see like individual eyebrows
kind of interesting sister james has got
that going on you could probably do it
do you think i could do that
no thank you
[Music]
what's the next look
oh hey if you were drunk enough you
would smash james charles
because you'd be like oh zoo alipa it's
impressive he did really good
it's very impressive but it just totally
just
makes you uncomfortable no i wouldn't
say it makes me uncomfortable it's just
it's like okay now i see [ __ ] james
charles when
you know it's like so if you if you ever
like
beat off to the fantasy of her and then
all of a sudden it's james charles there
no you know what i mean like sometimes
you can't control your imagination
it's like james charles hi sister
that's a shame i'm sorry to hear that
that's it just you know it's
you know shout out to the web i mean
shout out to the website that use
james charles what the hell that's weird
let's watch some videos okay first of
all you guys remember sam pepper
yeah well i do but i don't know actually
if the audience does
he's one of the original [ __ ] pranksters
of uh
youtube like back in the day he was like
uh
cancelled right yeah big time but he was
a huge deal on youtube for a minute
what was he cancelled he did this one
like inappropriate pranks
so he did a prank that okay this was
super weird but he was like grabbing
or what was it yeah he was grabbing her
having asses of people
he had like a fake hand
and he was grabbing a girl's ass with
the fake hand being like i didn't touch
you
and everyone's like this is mega [ __ ]
up
but then he's saying he tried saying oh
it was
god it was one of the weirdest he made
this whole big video being like this was
all a social experiment but it wasn't
he tried to spin it like he meant to do
it all and he knew how people react but
it was like a total [ __ ] lie and
everybody knew it
oh wait they are getting divorced kim
and this is breaking news
oh doesn't that happen every week the
sun appears to be
this is not this is variety reporting
and they say they've confirmed
well okay oh wow ian did you know about
this
literally like 30 minutes ago this
article was posted kim kardashian files
for divorce from kanye west
and weirdly it says she's filing for
conservatorship over his estate
[Laughter]
ian can we get your your thoughts on
this breaking news
yeah i mean you know it's never divorce
never a good time
you know hope the kids are all good
wow very diplomatic yeah i mean what is
it it's not it's not it's not funny or
you know very just feel bad yeah
it always sucks to see jesus
flavor alone took it down quite a bit
so i already saw an article like that
somewhere recently and i
and it also said like this is for real
happening and then i
and then nothing happened i think the
difference is that she filed
uh she's actually filed maybe maybe
they've been talking about it so it was
real let's hear let's read this yada
yada kim kardashian
divorce is eminent imminent
yadda yadda sources are close
okay who cares oh also sam pepper did
the killing best friend
yeah well kim's available i wonder who's
going to
who's going to swoop in on that eligible
bachelorette
i wonder how long before she is dating
ian there's probably a million people
and
honestly um
[Music]
i just i guess wish them the best i
don't know
yeah yeah for sure yeah that was ian's
point which was boring but i
questioned it so anyway he did this one
at this other prank
so if he was he was almost cancelled
from that one then he did another one
that absolutely buried him
where he he pretended to kidnap a friend
and i think he had a mask on he had a
mask on
and then to like threaten to kill him it
was like this really traumatic crazy
thing it was all fake by the way
they pretended like it was real youtube
erased it everybody was talking about it
it was just
horrible it's just horrible and he
disappeared off the internet
yeah it was a tr it was kind of like a
really early cancellation
right right you had never we had no idea
i don't think it was even considered a
cancellation
that word wasn't even really used yeah i
think just
everybody turned on him and he
um man he had the worst reputation ever
yeah so now he's on tick tock this
should show up on my feet and this is
going viral it's so embarrassing like oh
my god these pranksters are like
literally like [ __ ] cockroaches
they're unstoppable they got like
soulflow
joey salads they just they go from one
platform
to the other just kobe person isn't kobe
person
you know what i mean they just it's a
prank bro
you know how like uh during world war ii
the russians
scorched earth that's what they did
that's what these pranksters are doing
they leave nothing left for the rest of
us they just scorch earth
moving from platform to platform this
has six
so this one's going super viral that's
six million views it was just posted
less than 24 hours ago
oh my god like first of all it doesn't
look anything like justin bieber
it does it's not even convincing in the
slightest bit
people are buying this loving this on
tick tock let me show you this
look at this guy that's not justin
bieber it's not even close
also what he says is not funny
what you call a girl from canada who
can't sing
justin bieber is a girl jokes was that
like 2008 2009-ish
that was all that's not your id anyway
anyway all the comments were like ah my
respect for this guy's up i love this
guy
i was like oh brother here we go sam
[ __ ] pepper on tick tock
watch out people this [ __ ] idiot's
back they just send you a pic
oh you sent me a close-up of this uh
yeah here's jack
excuse me my new avatar for my for the
podcast
there's justin bieber justine
weaver
justin bliber
let's see what other [ __ ] he's up there
i challenge sam and we agree
that if he wins i will dump my love
jarvis
and i will date him but as you can see
i was in the lead oh it's an ad they're
using
energy cans so [ __ ] dumb i can't do
it
when ten thousand dollars whipped cream
to the face eat a jalapeno or drink a
bang
it's my turn dude they just literally
make bang videos
so nervous oh my gosh please they're
like this energy drink that has like
infiltrated
tick-tock it's like a meme where
everybody's talking about bang
energy it's like everywhere i've never
had a banana drink
what's the thing you people actually
walk around drinking bang
we did like a we did a deep dive on it
once but i don't think we ever actually
used it on the show
the the ceo is like a freak he's wait
did we
where's bank energy evil boys bang
injury not paying me i won't bait that
bang money
that's a good question i don't know bro
yeah this
this guy jack a walk take a walk jack
jack thing
we either have to drink and eat a pie
eat a jalapeno or drink a bang
please get the bang please get the bang
oh god
this is some compelling stuff sam pepper
yeah there i
am uh-huh she's so cute who is she oh my
god i don't know
oh here he goes this is a dude
huh oh is he gonna get the bang is he
gonna get the bang
no it's gonna get the jalapenos
come on no oh we got the whipper into
the face
yeah this is some really dog [ __ ] when
ten
thousand dollars well it's all about
fake content so i think it's just like
um just a new wave of fake stuff on tick
tock this one has 10 million views let's
see what he did
sam that i would date him if he got a
red cup into the other red cup and he
was it all about yeah i'm not gonna [ __ ]
him unless he can achieve this
yeah hey listen buddy you can only get
my panties if you can get a cup and a
cup
like oh thank god i don't have to date
this guy like look at him he's like so
not athletic
i was like this is definitely not gonna
work like he's not gonna get it like
look at him yeah
1.3 million likes man this is like kind
of sad to watch
it kept hitting me in the face too oh
she's holding a bang girl you
those bang people got you in under their
thumb
when did this turn into a beautiful
world look at it just holding the bang
like oh my god
i guarantee you that girl don't drink
bang that bang can't the size of her
head
crying everywhere like it was it was
pretty crazy but then
during this one i was like oh wait a sec
wait a sec oh oh
oh no god i was like oh no oh you gotta
[ __ ] me now
you gotta give it up anyways i was like
wow this guy he really deserved this
[Music]
kicking me now 10 million views on that
tick tock's amazing man
all right yep i don't know why
why is she in charge of his channel i
thought this was the sam pepper channel
so here it is
i have the craziest treat what is this
the big channel
bang dude when did you just turn into a
bang spokesman
all right sam tell me about bang energy
drink my backyard you've got to see this
you've got to see this bigger inside
than it is on the outside you've got to
see this it's actually
really really trippy yeah
whoa it's like okay am i not supposed to
acknowledge that bang is like
he's holding it perfectly am i literally
not
am i supposed to ignore that what the
[ __ ] this is so weird it's massive in
here
why what's with the can the craziest
treehouse
oh my god maybe it's a joke it's not
it's gotta be a parody
this is not a parody it did oh my god
it has to be a bear at first i thought
wait okay look at this
he's not acknowledging it and it's fully
in the shot this is sam pepper
that has to be apparently this is my
tree house is way bigger
inside than you think here it is my
backyard you've got to see this actually
way bigger inside than it is on the
outside you've got to see this it's
actually
really really trippy love please tell us
if this is a parody look in the
he's holding a comments great craziest
thing
i didn't realize this was such a
treasure trove
oh we got kate comments about my um
about my diet
no you're living oh this is just the
general chat no wonder here i'm in the
general chat for some reason but i'll
read this
general chat it's just the discord with
everybody as a nutritionist it pains me
to see how ethan is struggling with his
food choices
i want to help him meet his goals
without feeling like he has to suffer
how can i offer my expertise you can't i
have i'm getting zach's expertise that's
all the expertise i need
that's right yeah yeah no beans sorry
i already tried working with a
nutritionist you didn't
that that was everybody's a nutritionist
yeah you tried one time and it was
just it didn't work like try someone
else
oh the bang ceos tweeted out to jam to
real donald trump your brilliance has
fueled the most epic turn of events in
history of politics god bless the
inevitable trump wins
that's been that's the bang guy he is a
legend
this is him look at the bang ceo oh i'm
talking oh my god
trying to tell you this guy is look at
the get a load of this guy quite a
character
just just do google images bang ceo
well here love sent me the bang now i'm
i'm going down the bang hole y'all on
the bang hole
you're just a you're just a light weight
here love sent me the bang energy
oh wait no send me his tick talker send
me something interesting to watch
bro sam why is this the bank channel
what the [ __ ] every goddamn video is has
bang in it
things that i owned that just don't make
sense
this is
here let's see let's see if there's bang
in this one okay wait i can't
here thinks i owned it hey [ __ ] you sam
pepper
here's a cop i'm sure this one's gonna
watch this hey excuse me i've never been
a cop car can i just sit down for a
minute yeah check it out
yeah of course get out this is not fake
you have like an aux in this
no way okay listen to this one
[Music]
get out of here okay look at this
cocktail watch this
[Music]
sam pepper is on tick tock oh
boy he was trying so hard for a while to
rebrand on youtube
and it wasn't really succeeding so
the winner gets to drink bang winner
gets to drink bank energy
[Music]
i think i just saw oh here's
oh 7.5 million in summer for a while you
know it's been wondering what's inside
your pants
can they find out i got a snake in my
pants
summer yes
what oh i thought i heard zach say ethan
was it in this video
breathing oh breathing on me i see that
that did sound like anyway
the bang hole is crazy man that was a
fresh
the fresh wild run all of a sudden i'm
craving bang energy i put the bang
ceos uh instagram in the chat if you
want to check them out
okay here we go down the bang hole y'all
i didn't plan for this but now here we
are
1.1 million followers ceo of bang energy
he is a legend if you scroll down
so this is how you know someone has a
really good page 1.1 million
followers 400 likes
[Laughter]
that's good [ __ ] bro there he is on the
right there
what's with this what are they marketing
to kids they want kids to drink bang
energy it's got like a my little pony
no he's just so edgy really and young
here he is don't tell tell me thank god
oh no i'm getting major jimmy lee vibes
from this paying energy guy
you're right i hate everything how about
this
i mean it's just exactly talking around
i can't believe there's still people
making money in energy drinks like
i mean just it's like there's red bull
they did it you know just buy red bull
like monster came out they're like now
red bull's not hard enough you need
[ __ ] monster jizz
you need radioactive monster jizz is
that never enough from the energy drink
space
what's the other one that's the same
[ __ ] as rock star
that's the other big oh i would dude if
you're actually walking around something
called rockstar you should just [ __ ]
have a heart attack
oh bang is just a nightmare what's that
i had a friend that drank six
rock stars a day in high school is he
still alive yeah
he said one time his piss was green yeah
like no joke
i believe that this is him
i'm super impressed dude
oh my god look at his chain
here look at him welcome friends check
this out we moved all
[Music]
additional pieces of new killer
equipment
search the world for it to bring you the
bang now we're bringing you the bang
we're going to take you to the
bring me the bang boy
photography i bet you this guy injects
[ __ ] into his [ __ ] because he can't get
it up
there's people with like extreme ed that
have to inject some kind of crazy
chemicals into their dicks to get hard
i bet you he does that
hold on baby let me get my syringe
get inside the big gym
[Music]
follow me so
how old is this guy because he's trying
to look young but obviously he's super
old
wake up wake up wake up wake up big boy
now they're still doing construction
this is the 911 of energy drinks
59 59
that's pretty insane he's almost 60 and
he's creeping around
all banged out
what are you talking about dude what are
you talking about just stop
so this is sam sam and this guy are
close oh my [ __ ] look at this photo
everybody stop what you're doing and
look at the screen right now
dude you can't be serious
oh my god oh oh and read the caption i
was right yeah
grounding sun great sex killer pumps
what great sex
grow up great sex
can you imagine having great sex with
bang boy
yeah that guy injects in his [ __ ] i've
never been more sure of anything in my
life
how does that work the injection yeah
well
are you making it out no no it's a real
thing it's a real thing i don't know
exactly the
the chemistry but i know like if you
have a total noodle dick
and nothing works there's like the most
extreme version is you
you shoot your dick up with some kind of
hormones or
adrenaline or something and it makes
your dick hard so yeah
dude why is he what does he think people
really want to see his tit from that
angle
oh this guy is [ __ ] awesome that's
crazy
titties
i just get the vibe that is like hanging
out with um
18 year old sam pepper yeah exactly
so wow i didn't know about all this bang
[ __ ]
i wonder how she's paying sam pepper to
turn his whole identity into being the
bang spokesman
reach out to me bank ceo i'm available
don't want to work with him you don't
work with bang
bang energy you know there's like
warnings on those kinds of energy drinks
now saying don't drink if pregnant
it's awesome may cause birth defects if
you drink bang
energy
disclaimer look at our ceo a disclaimer
this
might end up looking like our ceo also
let me tell you this guy's not a [ __ ]
chemist you know what i mean like you
have no business formulating an
energy drink dude no he's formulating
his money in the bank
great sex
great sex he literally said that okay
here we go
this is disgusting we recently saw what
we saw a guy scratches crotch and smell
it is that what we saw
the german coach right
yeah so this guy here is another
university coach
jim boheme picks his own booger and eats
it during a game
it's a lot nc state history
bro what the [ __ ] dude stop you
no i hate it wait does he have the mask
pulled down too yeah
because he's picking his nose how are
you gonna pick your nose and eat your
booger if you have with a mask on
he did it so fast like he was super
experienced at it
does he think people wouldn't notice
because it's so fast
oh i can't they're so disgusting eating
boogers is one thing i just
i find it the most i've never could
never understand that
one of y'all eat boogers because
statistically
some people do it so just fess up it's
not me
i've always found it even as a kid i
thought that was so gross
somebody fess up who eats their boogers
a b you eat your bugs no sir
i don't believe you i've seen them do it
ian is kind of quiet
ian you eat your bugs no are boogers
keto
that's a good question maybe not
love you beat your bugs no
no you guys are lying i mean
if zach didn't hate it so much i would
have i would again pull jack
i'd rather eat turd than a booger i
believe the sack
i mean jack doesn't lie about this stuff
so no i believe him
you know
my hunch is on uh my hunch is on ap
eating his boogers
with peace and love
god bless but what do i know i couldn't
know for certain
i'll tell you i'll eat a booger before
before downing mayo like zach
really i would take the mail yeah you
eat your boogers baby now the sauce is
so nasty to me i don't know why
yeah i would eat mayo easily before the
booger
all right this is this is old but gold
as it gets
this [ __ ] blew my mind i'm so glad you
enjoyed this because i was dying
yeah i mean this is such a timepiece too
like what year is this from
it's 99. yeah so laura croft you know
who lorcraft is the tomb raider
protagonist with
big ass titties tight as l everyone beat
off to lara croft
now you all can own up to that right
i didn't have a playstation like i was
aware of her but i didn't have a place
to silence
because like it's a kids game but this
girl is so [ __ ] packing
tight pants big ass titties and a tight
or
her tails are like kind of sharp and
triangles yeah but not when you're okay
you use your yeah they're like straight
up
like pointy but they got more voluptuous
yeah as the graphics got better but that
was all i needed at that age i was like
show me the [ __ ]
you should look up the old oh yeah there
here yes
no that's the new one see that one's not
as hot it almost seems subtle compared
to today's
the new exactly the new laura croft
isn't as hot because
they're trying too hard to make her
realistic but i'll show you the one that
was the most hot for me hold on
this that one was good that was one of
the good ones
i mean here this was the most hot for me
i swear to god this one
this one that was the one i noted too
because that's all you need as a kid
you're like holy [ __ ]
but then there was the one there was one
that was really good too this one
like oh let's go dude that whole idea of
a girl looking like this for some reason
i think
of angelina and julie did she yeah she
did she did
did you like her no no no
not really like who's this like
would you rather [ __ ] this or this like
hello
this is
that was everything so anyway
this game was superb this is what laura
croft looked like she was a sex icon
this is what it looked like when this
video took place in 99
everybody's playing this game tomb
raider so
they bring out tomb raider to these kids
it's incredible yeah what about lara
croft
in tomb raider she's dropped to improve
lots on that
but it would be almost like yeah she was
in the room with you it actually almost
looks like a real person in
parts of it it looks
okay it's fairly unbelievable yeah okay
that's what i imagined you know what i
mean that's what i saw
so like there's no plan that's kind of
what
like there's no plan
the kids literally don't know what to do
[Music]
and it goes on for so long
look at these four kids i mean i wake up
wake up miss lara croft
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
all right boys
i believe their eyes are here yes
that was pretty good huh wake up wake up
wake up i didn't
go back and wake up oh elo okay you're
not gonna like this
i think it's worth watching i disagree
with the premise but
somebody says that you sound like
ricegum when you laugh in this moment
this one's great so this one
so hit play me the ricegum one zack
okay fine
okay wait this one's great okay go ahead
do you have either soundbite isolated
do you have that isolated zach yeah
oh you are yeah
then plate right
yeah i mean braces is way worse because
you're just giggling and he's going
drink it
okay what does rice come up to i heard
from is ricegum making content still
i've ever heard his name in years at
this point
let's see what he's up to oh he hasn't
uploaded in seven months what is he
doing
streaming on twitch oh no
i think everyone just moved on from
youtube it's just easier they just make
more money on twitch
they've just kind of like it's like you
you get kind of criticized on on one
platform but it stays there
like yeah it's another platform and it's
all new
wait he's really popular on twitch is
that right
some of these vods have here this is
from 20 hours ago here let's watch this
this video is only available to
subscribers
but it has four half a million
what the f you know how do you know
everything about twitch love what is
going on with this
he's he's young he's a he's a zoomer
he's
he's with it man yeah but i think those
views are
counted from the live as well
i just need your consent or serious type
[ __ ]
i'm not showing this because it's
actually [ __ ] up so just say yes and
we good
and just say yes okay yes yes
you know i'm out here yo what the [ __ ]
is this the role playing
gta how was that wait what
they roll they're playing gta role
playing oh yeah that's like super
popular now
what yeah like it's the only thing on
twitch right now yeah it's like
it's it's the new craze right now on
twitter what is it
you just role play on twitch yeah and
like sir like
how does that work you're in certain
situations and i don't watch that
just take it seriously
do you like it love i mean you tell me
about it because you're the expert
yeah it's really entertaining but it's
yeah i mean rp has a like a weird
reputation i guess but it's pretty
entertaining to watch
huh yeah am i role playing right now
maybe you tell me i don't know
you could probably get into the biggest
server that would be fun to watch you
i know uh hassan has gotten really into
it recently
so how does it work you're in different
situations where you're like hey you're
you play different parts or you just go
in and be like hey this is me now
like third life [ __ ] well it's a open
world
uh game so you can go wherever you want
i guess
it sounds like a lot is it sexual or no
you know we knew that we didn't have any
heavy come on
you can't blame a guy here you know jack
you ever do role play
like sexual role play
i don't remember what kind of roles have
you done
no comment oh come on
now i'm curious what kind of roles you
done give me something
toss me a bone here uh i was a jar of
mayonnaise and
now seriously
i'm doing keto for you against
everybody's advice
and you can't even tell me you pretended
to be a baby and let
me change your diaper you're doing it
for yourself not me
don't twist this you're my guru i am
and i'm advising you it comes from inner
self
let's make a count here uh myself
dan and a.b are all against it right
you guys are skinny i mean i
it's not that i'm necessarily against it
i just it's just it's
i don't think it's going to work i don't
yeah it's not it's okay
but how are you going to maintain
afterwards if you lose a bunch of weight
dan's a hater
i don't think i just did not hate him oh
i didn't learn that he's got a song that
says dan the hater
damn the hater what about ian
can he speak logic to you ian what do
you think
i mean i don't want to be you know dan
level hater but
um i don't know i've worked here a few
years now
and i've watched you do you've watched
me get fatter and fatter and
fatter i've watched you do what five six
different
sort of like fad diets i think you move
too quick
and i think you have to have a very
stable schedule
that's very very locked in well i'm
trying to find one that like i'm
it works for me you know what i mean so
that's what i'm trying i'm trying stuff
that works for me
and when i maybe but something loses
weight you guys are going to be all well
we were wrong
yes exactly thank you zach two [ __ ]
weeks guaranteed
two weeks two weeks that's short term i
guess we're more in
the long term question you know like
short term you can lose weight but don't
worry i haven't i've been able to lose
any [ __ ] weight
okay fat pathetic piece of [ __ ] no don't
put yourself down
you're keto man now you're stud i
apparently i don't reach full ketosis
for like three to five days so bear with
me that's
okay man you're gonna lose your water
weight your stomach's gonna go down
trust me wait water weight that doesn't
sound helpful
yeah like your bloat you know you lose
your blood yeah but it's just water it's
not real weight loss
well right but i mean that's step one
you're gonna see results yeah
why am i losing water weight well do you
start by losing your bloat first then
you get
your bloat yeah i'm starting to think
zach doesn't know what he's talking
about
what do you what do you mean you're
listening to a dude with the backwards
kangal cap i don't know
[ __ ] you danny you're just mad because
you can't rock this [ __ ]
he has a point then
zach dude you showed me a picture of you
you were so
big you looked like a different person
and now you're like suave ass
cool [ __ ] you [ __ ] porn stars
now bro and do role play
role tell me about the role play give me
one anecdote and i'll stick with keto
come on i can't i can't it's that bad
i can't i can't i can't illegal [ __ ] no
not illegal
taboo [ __ ] no no no no i'm
i'm just i'm zipping my mouth did you do
a role play with the porn star was it
with like a girlfriend no
no no no
it must be embarrassing
okay if i glue how about if i set a
milestone
and then will you tell me if i lose a
certain amount of weight you lose 50
pounds i'll tell you
and then you have to put mayonnaise on
your dome at 200 pounds dan
right whenever that happens that's a
standing offer right it's a standing
officer that's true
all right i get all kinds of good things
to look forward to
dan should mail up that dome
[Laughter]
all right let's push forward i am
dreaming of jalapeno bacon
chicken steak no beans no beans
my brother lost over 100 pounds on keto
yeah no people have currently been on
keto yeah losing weight as long as
you're consistent
it will work that's see that's the
problem i don't
you were already cheating yesterday it
was day one and you were already
cheating ethan
yeah but it wasn't like i had a few
[ __ ] peters they either put myself
like oh my god dan you're such a man
garbanzo beans
yeah oh yeah goodbyes or beans now how
do you
do you get tempted easy that's my
question
well here's the thing i'm gonna try this
diet i i don't know i mean
i don't know let's see i think i'll get
better at it
and finding good keto foods that i can
eat
yeah they make a lot of keto products
too so does it really make sense to be
eating keto ice cream like what's the
point
if you're eating keto ice cream it's
less sugar
i mean practically no sugar uh no
to few carbs um what about exercise are
you supposed to exercise
i mean yeah obviously no i'm not doing
it
but that's not part of the thing i mean
you will lose weight
fast on keto i mean but when i did i ran
every [ __ ] day
so it was just terrible are you sure it
wasn't just the running
no it was keto because there was a
period where i didn't run for like two
weeks and i was still
losing weight two weeks but you were
running every day
for the yeah yeah i'm gonna start a big
thing
but i'm telling you lots of people lost
tons of weight on keto
yeah but i just feel like okay just
watch
watch the fireworks baby you're gonna
stick with it
you stick with it and i guarantee man i
guaran [ __ ] teeth
what about wearing a shirt zach you wear
a shirt on keto
what does that mean i was actually gonna
i was gonna ask are you not wearing a
shirt under your jacket oh you're not
wearing a shirt zack stand up for me
zach what the hell am i gonna dress like
that angle
but i wasn't sure ethan that'll be you
before you know it
i'm just jealous of this lush chest
hairy
i am you're like five years younger than
me i have no chest hair
that guy i mean my like a lot of people
are saying
that it's really about changing your
lifestyle and i think that
yeah everybody's a specialist
everybody's a [ __ ] specialist of
course if i could just snap my fingers
and then not
care about your face of course it's
about changing lifestyle that's not
helpful to me
i'm looking for a cheat i'm not looking
for a cheat i'm just losing i'm looking
to lose 50 [ __ ] pounds
by tomorrow it will happen
that's not a cheat there's lipo you
could just
go do the lipo no i'm not doing all
things are possible with god
get your stomach stapled that's for like
600 pound people
you you will be okay you will do this i
guarantee you've got to get zach he
changed his whole [ __ ] life and he
was running every day forgot to mention
that a little bit of a break
because i was starving myself on
nutrition 1000 calories a day they
literally
said on the nutrisystem pamphlet don't
exercise because you are not getting
enough calories you believe that [ __ ]
well it's probably a safety thing like
they don't yes but that's how dangerous
their [ __ ] diet is
they say they got all the carbs you were
eating on that like you you were so many
carbs
you eat carbs now zach uh i mean i would
say i'm less strict
on keto um as i was
um but i'll have like a low carb
tortilla something like that
what's a low carb tortilla is in
tortilla just carbs
yeah but they make low carb low calorie
ones
it's good [ __ ]
i'm doing it i don't care what anybody
says i'll die doing keto
i'll die in a pool of bacon grease and
butter
there you go man
born to be wild joe rogan is my
spirit animal
i'm going to be eating elk before the
end of the week
here you guys want to watch some funny
[ __ ] this is my favorite video ever
i used to laugh at this [ __ ] video
oh my god me and sean balog back in the
day
we would just die watched it at some
point already on the podcast
it's probably a while ago it's less
funny with the whole backstory because
you feel bad for him
let's cut this [ __ ] because i don't want
to feel bad i just want to laugh
[Applause]
brian charges
just repeating it but like have you ever
seen anybody eat [ __ ] this hard in your
life
yeah i'm gonna mute it i don't want to
feel bad boom
let's go dude
he's fine you guys by the way anyone
worried
[Applause]
but have you ever seen anyone eat [ __ ]
that hard and like
he did it to himself man
shout out to his family
i don't know why i'm not it's not that
funny to me anymore
okay it was evolved
[Music]
what about this one here's another
gymnast uh
accident similar but honestly not it's
good
not as good it's the same accident
though
i'm starving
oh my god do you guys have any intel on
this slide because like
this [ __ ] blew my mind okay ela
like whoa explain this
what kind of [ __ ] slide is this the
guy ragdolled out of there
at full speed
this one hits far right did someone mess
with that
i don't know but that one looks like
like traumatic neck injury
that last one it doesn't look right
[Laughter]
oh man is this for kids i mean what is
this
but it looks like it doesn't look like
it was
professionally made look at this well
clearly not
that's got to be russia right i mean
where else could something like this
exist
i think it's a water slide that's frozen
but even still it just stayed in those
corners way too hard dude
how is it a water slide it goes into a
sand pit
well like it could have been drained for
winter like in michigan i've seen
stuff like this because at the bottom
you can see a little bit of the
other parts of the park right there like
the mushroom thing
so you think if there was water in it i
think if there was water you'd hit it
just as hard
yeah you'd be going just as fast
last quarter so hard
zack i love that you hit that sound
button
every time he talks it's so [ __ ] up
i love you amy i i you know you know i
love you too man
all right y'all ready for some weird
[ __ ] yep what's that once again this was
all on my tick tock feed
okay this one's actually not as bad as
the other one but here you go apparently
people wash
themselves in cow urine what
so you you can and you will stop it
well imagine soaking your hand why is
she doing that what is this
you could see them pinching it off like
humans do where they go
why are people bathing is there any
intel on this
what i love that you're playing splashy
splashy with the urine too look at that
splashy splashy
girl you got [ __ ] you ain't
so anyway that one ain't nothing next
compared to the next one trust me with
peace and love
this next one's going to [ __ ] you up
this was on my home page on tick tock
and this is why i will continue
the day i die saying tick stock's the
best social
world because real quick uh cow urine
is used in medicine in india myanmar
nepal and nigeria wow urine and cow dung
has
benefits as fertilizers the proponents
claims about curing diseases
and cancer have no scientific backing
according what
cow urine doesn't cure cancer how do you
know
this is on my homepage y'all this is
just [ __ ] i was like what am i
looking at
i guess if you have nothing else no i
know
i mean the cows are seeking the cow is
clearly drinking a lot of water
yeah that's a lot of liquid
and then the song they're playing is um
shower by becky g
shower and this one is eating the poo
poo all over the place
[Laughter]
dude
[Laughter]
i love that purple color
either the guy is bathing in urine yeah
but it's so stylish
it's a nice purple
what else do you like what else do you
like about this
um dude that cow is like a
gaping vag
[Laughter]
it wouldn't be after dark without a
little urine shower
look it cures cancer apparently
what else do they say it does well it
says
just cures and i was using all kinds of
folk medicine
i mean yeah in in india and a lot of
southeast asia cows are
are holy animals so i'm not surprised
right
i mean he's not drinking it yeah
and that's what i'm saying and he's
looking good while doing it
oh last week i was looking for this
slurpee tick tock that was removed and i
we got the backup so i'm excited to
share with you guys
the slurpee video a lot of people are
saying it's fake this ain't fake i
thought went to this guy's channel
and he had like all these celebratory
videos him with the slurpee
like chilling with his family on a swing
this this video is real as a heart
attack which he will be having i
guarantee
here we go one cup is one
i'm buying all the cups how many cups
this one this is four cups how much this
one
what's in the bucket slurpee
just listen just listen to what i'm
saying number five
that's five unreal this is unreal oh my
god
okay so wait what is taking the cable
that's going oh it's just so
it's his straw no so he can he goes in
the car with that
so he can like he'd be hitting slurpee
at any time anywhere
there's a video of him in his car with
the cable in his mouth
so it's like um that's
he's a [ __ ] king yeah he's a king
he's
he you know what maybe he did it his way
he that's a guy whose theme song is i
did it my way yeah he's
uh he's a true original i did it my
way
[Laughter]
that's his strong yeah
how do you get to this point what else
are you gonna do if you want some fresh
flour
it's actually the one i saw was longer
than this just this is what i'm saying
number five it's unreal this is unreal
so by the way there's someone going this
is unreal that's like his friend
it's not like oh he's a friend that is
is upset like yeah
this is unreal upsetting he's saying why
can't he just buy this
so it's not like a customer who's like i
can't believe it read alert
love is saying he's 99 sure it's an act
[ __ ] love you don't know why why do
you think that
as love love what did you get better
back that up you're calling them
but i mean there's a bunch of skits on
their tick tocks
with the same principle show me one
you'd like to show me one
no i don't have the link maybe the guy
loves slurpee and he records himself
getting slurpee
he's
it of course this guy's done it
yeah he's got skittles this is a man
that loves slurpee
no if he's gonna you have to acknowledge
that if he's got skits on his
kids his kids would everybody in the
chat
neither of you yeah i love you you don't
understand american gluttony right
i'm with 10
when i see the extra large cups it's
like so unappealing to me
okay that's why you're did you know
that's why i decided
did you not see this is a man that
drinks slurpee
every time zach agrees with you always
go what a surprise just to mess with him
wow
so we need to know where ian stands i'm
sorry i went to the bathroom i have no
idea what you guys know
this whole thing with ian too much
just waiting for love is trying to prove
me wrong
it's slurpee slurpee's not the keto
right
i'm just saying if they do like you're
sugar if they do like
tick-tock pranks then it's mostly he
doesn't do pranks
love is wrong he doesn't know what he's
talking about
i know for a fight this is fake oh you
better back that [ __ ] up
right [ __ ] house i step into my house
when you say hold on we gotta
we gotta define what we mean by fake i
mean he is feeling like a bucket full of
slurpee what's fake absolutely
yeah nah it's a skit it's a skin it's
not a skin
it's not a skin
you're backtracking you're saying the
election wasn't real you come into my
home
and you tell me that this is going to be
no bit is a skit
on the day of my ketosis day number one
you come to me and tell me slurpee is
not keto i know it was you freedom
[Music]
with peace and love i can't with love
and love i can't do this
[Music]
and you're going to come and say the
slurpee is fake and without the receipts
[Music]
okay all right go ahead
something let's see that's the first one
all right hang on
use the double golf cup for the [ __ ]
slurpee
this right here this is slightly cup
you use this [ __ ] every time you make
a big deal bet i always paid for it
what's what's wrong you and my friend
let's be friends this one is the slurpee
cup don't care about your scooby cup
wait this isn't on his channel is it
this is someone else how do we even know
that's the same guy
oh it is the same guy for sure
oh here here the original is back up
okay here's the let's see
all right this is the full experience
the original didn't have the employee
blurred
he probably had to take it down to not
get the employee in trouble because it's
not staged
that's exactly what happened no but it
was removed
because in the first one the employee's
face was visible
and the re-upload his face was blurred
out but it is if he's
if he's pranking the employee it's still
a prank
he's not pranking anybody the employee's
telling him you can't get that many
slurpee you can't do that
and he's filming it but it's real but is
he
buying it just for the prank or is he
really
that guy there's a follow-up video there
go back
to the whole thing this is foreign
this is unreal still the fact that he
went to a 7-eleven with a bucket i mean
that takes balls to do
that
one second i wouldn't have this already
clearly you're going longer than that
[ __ ] liar you gotta you bought a pipe
bucket this ain't no pike
this is a crazy straw i didn't buy a
bucket about a slurpee
cup this is the brand new swervy cup
okay on the way home you go over a bump
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] falls all over the
car i told you this is that new design
7-eleven just made this it's spill proof
you doesn't matter what you can do
nothing's gonna fall out of it
this is [ __ ] man okay it's a gag
it's a gag
okay but i still think this is real
this is a real moment this is a real
interaction with him
trying to make anybody's doing it for
the video it's not
right he's he's filling up the bucket
for whoa whoa whoa whoa
that is not love says this is fake
this is real it's a gag
but this is real now it's a real
interaction between him and the ploy
no one was talking about love said it
was fake
clarify love and i don't think that's
what he meant
yes it is so i i think they're both in
on it
oh you think yeah yeah he thinks that's
why i was trying to
define what we mean by facebook he
thinks the whole thing stage
i think he was filling up a bucket of
slurpee
for his stupid sketch yeah and the
employee got mad at him yeah
but originally didn't you think he was
just drinking that
for just that's like
yeah but he's being funny yeah because
i i'm pretty sure i've seen more of
these guys and
they both were talking of i i i
can't find it now but i will find it
until the next show is your boy
man why would you put the lid on top of
the [ __ ] glass like why do you care
what does it matter to you seven
eleven it's weird and strange is
different i'm just trying to be
different
kiddo this guy's whole channel is
dedicated to slurping you all gonna
[ __ ]
question yeah bottom line is everyone
was wrong about me
sorry how do you think about that
is that the explanation you're now
switching what you thought you thought
it was for real
that's i i i was saying it's fake
because he's not with some serious [ __ ]
okay whatever you're rewriting history
where's huh you're advertising for it
it's not here
huh that's what i wanted people on this
thing [ __ ]
manners where's the watermelon huh no
it's racist where's the pizza i don't
like it man this guy
this guy you gotta tip the beanie to him
he has a whole career out of slurp
again oh it's not a career i thought
yeah 100
if you guys want to follow the slurpee
experience
at mit at amit sphere
it's like atmosphere but i guess his
name is probably ammon
by a slurpee joe
biden oh so someone said i'm a giant
is that you kate i can't see you through
the camera okay
are you in there okay wake up are you
watching us kate
are you mean to me this guy definitely
loves slurpee though we can
we can yeah yeah okay this guy is a
slurpee
oh grandma y'all want to see some weird
[ __ ] i mean
i guess it's kick so there's a sport in
india called
karum carom carom and this guy is
apparently really good at it i don't
know i can't verify that or not but his
videos are fascinating to me
i've never heard of karum what is that
but his look and everything just
captivates me
and then he goes like oh then he does
his little thing
never seen that
he's the careroom king
i'm fascinated by your fascination of
this because like
how do we know if he makes it look
intentional but all he does is this
and then he could just be hitting i mean
no look
he called it well before it wound up and
knocked just doesn't
it just doesn't impress me though wait
you understand what the game is i'm
still trying to i don't know what the
game is but he's look he's ricocheting
and he's saying it's going to go into
this top left corner he points at it
i mean it doesn't impress me that much
clearly doesn't impress that much people
anyway because it doesn't have that many
views there's just another weird thing
on my home page
but his look interests me too like he's
got like justin bieber
here you know
and i can't tell if he's like 20 or 50.
i'm curious about the game
the lookout but look he just he
literally just does this
he just did this wake up what do you
mean
he tries to be like look what i'm gonna
do but all he does is like this
now you're living here watch out what he
does in the beginning watch his hand
movement
it's like i don't know nobody cares what
are you talking about
he's calling what it's going to do yeah
but he's he's
uh is doing that right so but he just
like you could barely follow what he's
calling it's just [ __ ] every move
looks the same
he ricochets it off the side it bounces
a bunch of times and ends up in this
hall like
every move looks exactly the same haha
[ __ ] i'm laughing because you big man
exactly
exactly all right you this is a again
this was just on my tick tock feed bro
i [ __ ] dare you to make sense of this
what
and by the way the guy doesn't crack a
smile or anything
this was on my home page bruh kicks the
guy in the nuts and then his heart is
pounding out of his chest the guy does
not crack a smile
he does not show any emotion no pain
nothing and then he walks off this is so
weird
yes sir
wow this was on my homepage this is what
tick tock does to me okay
so weird yeah this isn't my first rodeo
no okay we're gonna well how long we've
been going because
i feel like this is a good one to end on
uh two hours
bruh you want me to see some weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] lady gaga
lady gaga live let me show you this
clip from lady gaga live at south by
southwest
old or what old clip 2014.
pretty old
[Music]
lady gaga's jamming out on the drums
she's having a crazy time this girl is
making herself
gag oh not and she's
putting her fingers down her throat
right next to gaga and then she's
puking on lady gaga green oh green
neon green pew oh my god onto lady gaga
why yeah and lady gaga's drumming
through it
and she's just a lot of green
onto lady gaga's chest
and uh she's covered in green
vomit and she's drumming on her
she loves it gaga loves it
and she just walks off into the sunset
and gaga continues her set [ __ ]
nailed it
what is that rock and roll zack or
what was that is that rock and roll
that's some demonic [ __ ] man
oh that wasn't rock and roll i mean no
it is rock and roll it's very you know
just not sure if it's rock and roll or
what i uh
it's a first yeah i mean because like
ozzy ate a bat head off
i mean so what's the difference between
tearing a bat off and having a girl puke
on you
yeah yeah i guess nothing i mean minus
the rabies i guess you'll catch like
you know stomach flu or something
it's just pretty wild thought to be like
i want someone to puke on me
during a live set i don't think a lot of
people sign up to see that
but there it is well maybe they do i
mean
really yeah i think people were
expecting something crazy
really okay to i guess i don't know gaga
very well
i think she's come down a lot and now
but like
how's she saying the national anthem at
the inauguration
and you went yeah that's she's come a
long way from being puked on
there used to be this punk guy uh named
gigi allen who used to
perform naked and [ __ ] in his hand and
oh that's funny yeah
that's rock does that rock and roll
that's that's punk rock that's
that's some hard what would he do with
his turret once it was in his hand he
would like smear it all over his body
and oh yeah and piss on himself [ __ ]
gross he would cut himself
it was gigi was iggy was his music good
i mean it was punk rock you know um
he's angry huh god rest his soul
you ever been that angry that you [ __ ]
in your hand and smear it on your face
i can't say i have i've eaten mayonnaise
but that's pretty much it i don't know
if that's
totally comparable mayonnaise isn't so
much anger as desperation
i'm pretty desperate i'm just saying
like
[ __ ] on your hand and smearing on
your face it's hardcore
and he would do a naked too like fully
nude well
that doesn't shock me as much that seems
secondary to the [ __ ] aspect of it
yeah apparently this artist is like
that's her thing it's just puking
she like gets milk and dyes it a really
vibrant color and then pukes it onto a
canvas on the canvas
all right that's like her whole thing
which all right i don't know
art is art is it art is art love is love
it's art art is love and art is art i'm
not sure art is
art what if like you're doing an exhibit
you know she puts it up
it must smell right she does i mean
that's what she does
there was another video of her maybe
over time people are watching her do it
there's like and they're all like
applauding and she pukes
it's just i don't know it's like an
interesting gag i guess once but to
build your whole
career out of just puking ink colored
milk
his art art and you know she's gonna
think of some like really
elaborate explanation for why it's
interesting but it's like okay
you wrote that after you started puking
wake up
[Music]
there's this other girl who does this
egg plop she puts like
eggs injected with ink upper badge and
then and then pushes them out onto a
canvas
it's it's all performance art they get
pretty weird
performance art oh the same girl she
went into a public place
and butt naked with a box over a veg and
let strangers like
finger her
it's disgusting and there was a camera
in the box and you could see
his and you could see what people were
doing to her
jesus that one's more interesting though
i guess maybe than puking
or plopping eggs just because like from
the social aspect
you can see how weird people are
right i feel like zach would put his
hand in there
oh god no that that [ __ ] no
what oh no okay i thought
i mean is that well most of the people
who did do it were like
like on the verge of looking homeless
you know like it sounds
very like there's no consent there no
that
no no she was inviting people she was
inviting people to do that performance
yeah total concern yeah there was it was
not an assault
yeah i think that inspired the
cookie the cookie filling oh
color whoa
if you uh eat enough of these
damn she got her own oreo based on this
performance
i didn't know it was so iconic
good find ian bravo
got gotta shout out my brand sponsorship
all right well it's friday it's friday
rebecca black did you hear that that hot
new remix of the friday
song i didn't she dropped it oh wait i
did hear it
it was one of the worst things i've ever
heard yeah it wasn't it's like she
didn't try to make it better
no i mean maybe she realized that it was
only a thing because it was so bad so
she's
doubling down gogg and a meat dress i've
heard about this but i don't know some
of these guys on the crew were lying to
themselves saying they liked it but
it was not good is this actual meat
oh yeah it is gross what's the statement
here is she a vegetarian or something
or not i doubt it based off of what i'm
saying
on the meat show mark zuckerberg what
are your thoughts on this
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here
mark likes it ela you what do you think
about this as a fashion designer
and semi-vegetarian
well i don't know what was involved in
the making of this like was this
something
i'm sure it's designer was but
i don't know i mean it's kind of
interesting as yeah i agree
that's kind of interesting and i mean
the execution is pretty good
good draping on that meat i didn't know
that meat draped so well
i don't really listen to her music but i
always kind of liked her
just her thing
it was designed by frank ferner
ferdinand fernandez is that a joke
you're saying frankfurt like a sausage
no
is the artist who made it i'm not
familiar
i wonder if i can buy this in macy's or
something
does it come with a refrigerator too i
know that thing got a stink by the end
of the night
oh it was archived after being preserved
by a taxidermist as a type of jerky
so there's like a jerky they jerkified
this dress
and now it's sitting in a museum
i don't get that because i'm sure it
doesn't look
could you have a picture of the joker
that's okay yeah i was just thinking i
want to see what it looks like now
so she said somewhere
explain the following awards ceremony
that the dress was a statement about
one's need
to fight for what one believes in and
highlighted her distaste for the us
military's don't ask
doesn't tell police it doesn't say that
wait
it wasn't it wasn't a like a animal
rights protester no
gay people in the military yeah i'm
seeing multiple
reasons but yeah i'm not saying anything
this is her dress now how did it turn
into this
it's been jerkified it's just a big slab
of beef jerky
huh it still looks pretty good i'm kind
of impressed
a girl boss wait this does not mean
gay rights in the military this is a
woman in a meat dress
so i'm saying art is not art like
explain this to me again
it has to do with gays in the military
we need
how more so who is gay gays bombing
civilians in the middle east
let's see if we don't stand up for what
we believe in and we don't fight for our
rights pretty soon we're going to have
as much rights
i don't know if anyone has touched it
but what's the texture of the dress now
like
someone asked
if they said it's very hard if anyone's
wondering the
current texture of the dress very hard
like zach right now looking at this
dress
that's [ __ ] right like she clearly
just liked the meat dress and was like
ah
how do i make this interesting cause we
can apply this to
yeah i mean i thought gays in the
military no the first meeting
yeah that makes no sense the first thing
that i was thinking about is like
a statement on leather like if this was
a leather address
that would be a great statement because
if it was leather you wouldn't think
twice about it right
but it's meat then you realize how gross
it is that would have been a great
statement
but she's like i like meat there's tons
of pictures of me eating meat
so who is gay
it's not nobody's gay it's just uh right
that's a fair question who is gay
and i got news for you that means you're
gay
keto dress it's a keto dress
i could eat that dress
all right so guys uh
see you guys on the tuesday for fredbies
we'll be back
you know the whole gang will be back for
another slam
dunk fun week of explosive hot memes and
entertainment
this is history podcast the greatest
show
on the internet bar none i'm here to
announce
that i will not be moving to texas like
everybody else
i will be staying in california with
peace and love
not that there's anything wrong with
texas but everybody's yeah logan paul is
going to puerto rico that he's going to
get rob
like he's going to get robbed
it's not that's not a very nice thing to
say about
puerto rico right i'm a [ __ ] i
saw them
on tick tock i saw all the puerto ricans
blasting him insane there was all these
memes going around that like
the minute he gets off the plane i think
it's just because puerto ricans are like
not down with like
it's like kind of a colonial thing and
he's going there to evade taxes
so from what i saw on puerto rican tick
tock is that they're getting ready to
rob him
that was the jokes they were making they
can make that joke
okay right
so
god bless up i'm staying right
oh and um and uh and kim kardashian is
single so
happy hunting to iain slater oh wait
you're in the relationship
i'm sorry he wouldn't do that to his boy
right let me ask you a question ian
hypothetically
you meet what is this about kim
kardashian
okay you me you're single let's just say
you're single because i don't want to
complicate
things with your girlfriend who we all
love sam
what's the uh what's the percentage that
i'm gonna like what you say next
i think we should do a poll on that well
what is this music you don't have to
like it i'm just curious like
my question is this if you were single
you met kim kardashian at a party
you guys were hitting it off she was
clearly sending signals
would your fandom of kanye prohibit you
from making a move on
on kim or would you not care about your
allegiance to kanye
or would it make you maybe more enticing
make you more interested
that you could be you could have your
dick in the same place that kanye's once
was
thoughts what's going on in your head
i just laid it all out for you
obviously ian would go for it
that's what i think too but i don't know
if he's like love for kanye
like you know you're not supposed to
hook up with your bros yeah but i think
that love is faded kind of
would you make a move on kim or would
you respect kanye and pass the
opportunity
can't even conceive this hypothetical
situation
and uh i'd like to say hi to my
girlfriend who is watching
and i love you sam's not threatened by
kim
sam i promise is not threatened by kim
kardashian
what does that mean ian is not hooking
up with kim kardashian how dare you
okay well maybe he has a chance i'm
sorry
he's a great guy with a lot of redeeming
qualities
thank you yes the wrong answer
the answer is that it's a hypothetical
so she shouldn't have to worry
obvious well what is the chance that
ian's going to get
i think there's something i i forgot to
mention i totally
remembered yeah because we were talking
about zach's dream girl dua lipa and i
forgot that i own her
sunglasses oh yeah yeah
hold on let me just think do you think
ian is still afraid of the kanye
community turning on him
because like he doesn't play these kanye
games anymore and i don't are you afraid
of the
kanye community is that why you're
refusing to answer these
wait what yeah he is because so ian was
super deep
it is it's not it's that it just well he
started talking about it because he
was feeling bad for kanye because no
because he's in deep with the kanye
community they all know him now because
he's such a prominent voice
or was at least and so anytime he did
this they would get mad at him like dude
you can't talk about
[ __ ] kim kardashian this is not cool
and like
one time so i'm just saying you know i
think that's why he's so hesitant
i clicked on a link on twitter one time
and it it was like enter to win
what was it it was like duolippa's like
uh
something from her music video and i
clicked on it and i forgot
and then a few months later i got this
oh
what in the mail this was like years ago
and so what sunglasses sell
the sunglasses i wore when i did the
oreo thing these like belong to dual
leap
that's why you think it still has their
dna on it
maybe i was like zach do you want to get
your hands on these but you're saying
that anymore
are they like a brand or just some
kind of it was called a dual livery
why did they give that to you or like
why do you have why what
apparently she wore these at like a
concert or something
they're cool yeah so
shout out to duolingo yeah i wonder if
we can extract dna though from it
there's there's a lot of possibilities
once we can isolate our dna
duopoly
all right off the rails
god bless well that's exciting
do you think i think he would [ __ ] kim
if he was single and had the opportunity
why do you who cares oh my goodness
what do you mean who cares everybody's
wondering
literally all right have a great weekend
guys happy friday
take care of yourselves stay away from
those carbs
you're listening to this stay away from
those carbs what we got on the sink
but you can take one hit of miracle whip
right
ready ready
scott yeah i've seen people do this on
keto they fry
cheese into a bread like cracker yeah
that's great
you make parmesan no you make parmesan
you make parmesan crisps in the oven
those are really good so i can make a
sandwich with
cheese instead of bread and it's [ __ ]
fantastic
you think it's [ __ ] crazy but it's it
it works
and then well i could also just use
lettuce for the sandwich i'm gonna i'm
gonna fry a
[ __ ] is there like a limit do i need to
control myself can i just
fry a block of cheese i mean obviously
any like anything in life
anything in life yeah i'm gonna go make
some jalapeno
bacon poppers that sounds good thank you
all right guys take care we'll see you
next week god bless ma
forget about it huh all right shout out
bye bye bye bye
you're listening to the hd podcast what
we got on the scene
could it be papa shoe nights or build
elfin talking front wiper back wife
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew
goosing gaps with all the guests you'll
see the best